Speaker Kevin McCarthy speaking
just moments after the House
successfully passed
by a wide bipartisan margin.
A vote, a bill
to avert a debt crisis
here in the United States.
Gloria, you noted, as we were discussing
just a moment moments
ago, more Democrats
than Republicans
voting for this bill
in a Republican controlled House
of Representatives. Right.
And I think that's
going to be a sore point
for a bunch of Democrats.
The Progressive Caucus,
which didn't like this
bill, didn't ever take
an official position on it against it.
But in the House, you had the
Republican Freedom Caucus
take a position against it.
And so the Democrats held back a little
because they vote for debt ceilings.
They want to pay the bills.
And there were Republicans
who voted for it. 149.
And it sort of shows you how
the conservative Freedom Caucus
is an island
in the
in the Republican Party
in the House right now.
And I think that most Republicans
said, you know, we have to do this
because we are now a party
that has to show
that it can govern in the House.
And used to be the big concern
when it came to debt
ceiling fights of which
we've had almost every two to three years
for the last decade,
except to remind me
exactly when they voted for a two year
suspension
of the conversation altogether.
I think what's interesting
is hearing McCarthy there say
he's talking about the negotiation
and who came to the table
and who didn't come to the table.
He's not saying we held strong
until we got this, this and that
because he's trying to show
that they are engaging,
they are governing.
And I think the lesson of
the last couple of years has been
if you take it to the limit
on one of these fights,
you don't win with the public.
They don't look at you and say, oh,
thanks for crashing the economy
for a week.
There is a kind of political penalty
to doing it.
And I think they're acknowledging it
in a way,
and they've learned that lesson.
One of the
I mean, it is so interesting
because some of the polling recently
had seemed to indicate that
perhaps the public
maybe wanted
the spending cuts
in exchange for a debt ceiling.
But it seems like the deal
that was cut indicates that,
you know, the Democrats
kind of got slightly
more of what they wanted out
of this deal.
Republicans were a little bit more upset.
What do you make of Kevin
McCarthy actually making this move
and saying we got to cut a deal
no matter what?
Well,
I think, first off,
you can sit here and say,
I mean, a month ago
we were talking about
the Biden White House
and the Democrats at this position,
a clean debt limit increase. Right.
So it is a huge win
for Kevin McCarthy today
to accomplish what he did today
and the end vote total.
I know everybody's
going to try and spin it
on each side on it.
But the fact of the matter
is, 50% plus one is a win.
It doesn't matter
who voted for it, who voted against it.
If you want to vote,
you one end of the day.
And keep in mind,
the two people
that were two of the people
in this conversation,
Kevin McCarthy and Garret Graves,
they have worked in Congress
in the nineties.
They worked for
Kevin McCarthy, worked for Bill Thomas,
the first Republican Ways
and Means chair.
Garret Graves
worked for
Billy Tauzin
from Louisiana,
the first Energy and Commerce
Republican chair.
They know how the system works.
These are serious.
And so they sat down and they govern.
I think you have to give McCarthy credit.
I mean, he did get 149 Republicans.
He said he would get 150,
or somebody suggested he would also like
Joe Biden to like he's done this a bunch
and he did it under President Obama,
like his office.
And management
and budget director
who worked in House appropriations
for a very long time. L.Z.
Granderson is also here with us.
When Kevin McCarthy
was going through the crucible
to become speaker of the House, right.
He went through 15 rounds
and he said this will
this will teach us how to govern.
Was he right?
No, but he has to say it right.
He had to present the image
that this is their attempt
to try to
learn the lessons of the past and show
that it isn't just about saying no,
but that we can say maybe,
which is language for compromise.
You know, listen,
as you mentioned earlier,
we've had this conversation
a lot over the past decade.
And I tell you what disturbs me
most about this conversation,
it isn't whether or not
it's a clean bill or a negative bill.
It's whether or not you're going
after poor people
while trying to pass this bill.
And that's a reoccurring theme
Anderson, discussions.
And I think as we continue
to have this discussion in 20, 25
after the election,
we're going to be trying to figure out
what are we going to do
with a debt ceiling.
And I'm afraid that once again,
poor people,
people on welfare, people who need help,
are going to be the targets.
And it would be good
if we could actually have a discussion
that lifts up
the entire budget beyond just hurting
poor people.
Going forward.
Well,
I think
another thing to keep in mind here
and Congressman Massie,
you had a great point in that
this was a good exercise
to get us to the point
where we're actually going
to look at every program
in the form of the 13
appropriations bills.
So once the 302 tube allocations
come out for the subcommittees,
that's that's a cap on it's
subcommittee
in the Appropriations Committee.
But what I would like on
this is for a long time,
and I have to say, people
always say that and the
process is not psychedelic in a.
I do.
Now, McCarthy has to deliver on that.
I appreciate your optimism
that Congress will start to govern, but
we will see if that happens.